yeah anika I'm still fangirling and they
just all told different stories I'm
still fangirling but what are your
feelings when you hurt what were your
feelings when you heard that there was a
black princess that Disney was creating
I don't know what the feeling was but my
thought was I have to get that that's
for me I literally thought I have to do
that and and the Anika was was the
second person to to audition for for
Tiana before Dreamgirls actually had
come out but we were just blown away
we felt like I remember and we looked at
each other and said that's gonna be our
next princess even though we had a lot
of more auditions to come but we knew it
then you know it's this great this great
combination of like intelligence and
kindness and kind of like you know
bourbon on the rocks voice that she has
it was just great and and immediately
for a writer it's like oh she's gonna be
great you know great to write for
because the intelligence comes through
in every word she says and and there is
this you want to root for her you know
when you hear and I had met her or
anything
you just want to root for her and it was
just a blast so thank you
my first audition was the night that
Dreamgirls premiered in Los Angeles
I left the premiere I did not do one Bop
I did not go to a party I did not drink
a drink I went back to my hotel and I
made my sister-in-law come with me and
work with me on my lines for my audition
the next day the second audition I had I
was shooting a film a TV show terrible
in Australia in Australia and I had
flown out to Australia which is like 125
hours and I shot the next day after I
landed and the following morning I got
back on the plane and I came back to LA
and the very next day I had my second
audition for The Princess and the Frog
and never once did I feel oh my god I
can't believe I have to do all this
never once that I feel I was not where I
was supposed to be never once did I feel
like this girl was not me I felt like I
knew her from the moment I read the
sides and now I'm gonna cry
you